This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. From the always stunning, amazing award-winning radio diaries. You think I'm exaggerating, but I'm totally not. Here is Joe Richmond. It was strangely cold and foggy on the morning of July 28, 1945. The World War II was coming to a close, and the mood in New York City on that Saturday was cheerful. Millions were eating breakfast, running errands, and one 20-year-old woman was on her way to the 80th floor of the tallest building in the world. Her name was Betty
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。来自总是令人惊叹、屡获殊荣的《广播日记》。你以为我在夸大其词，但我完全没有。这是乔·里士满。1945年7月28日的早晨，天气异常寒冷且雾气弥漫。第二次世界大战即将结束，那个周六纽约市的气氛很欢快。数百万人正在吃早餐、跑腿，而一位20岁的年轻女子正前往世界上最高建筑的第80层。她的名字叫贝蒂。
Lou Oliver, and she spent her days going up and down and up and down the Empire State Building as the operator of elevator number six. While Betty worked that morning in her crisp uniform smiling at passengers, she couldn't have known that outside the building a young US Army pilot on his way to LaGuardia Airport was lost in the thick fog and flying low over Manhattan. She couldn't have known that the pilot of that B-25 had just narrowly missed hitting the Chrysler building, then Grand Central. She might have heard the roar of the plane as it got closer, and she might have wondered what it was, as she got called up to the 80th floor just before 10am. At the exact moment, the plane slammed into the 79th floor of the Empire State Building.
露·奥利弗，她每天的工作就是驾驶6号电梯在帝国大厦里上上下下。那天早上，贝蒂在电梯里穿着整洁的制服，微笑着迎接乘客，她不可能知道，在大楼外，一名年轻的美国陆军飞行员在前往拉瓜迪亚机场的途中，迷失在浓雾中，正低空飞过曼哈顿。她不可能知道，那架B-25轰炸机的飞行员刚刚险些撞上克莱斯勒大厦，然后是中央车站。当飞机靠近时，她可能听到了轰鸣声，也可能在想那是什么，就在上午10点前，她被叫到了第80层。就在那一刻，飞机撞上了帝国大厦的第79层。
Betty experienced every elevator rider's worst nightmare. Down she fell, floor by floor, more than a thousand feet to the sub-basement. What happened next put Betty Lou Oliver in the Guinness Book of World Records. Somehow air pressure built up as the elevator dropped, slowing the fall. Somehow, air pressure built up as the elevator dropped, slowing the fall. At the same time, thousands of feet of loose elevator cables were coiling up on the bottom of the shaft. When the elevator car reached the bottom, those cables acted like a giant spring to cushion the landing.
贝蒂经历了每一位电梯乘客最可怕的噩梦。她一层一层地坠落，跌落了一千多英尺，直达地下室。接下来发生的事情让贝蒂·露·奥利弗登上了《吉尼斯世界纪录大全》。不知何故，电梯下坠时产生的空气压力缓冲了坠落。不知何故，电梯下坠时产生的空气压力缓冲了坠落。与此同时，数千英尺长的松动电梯缆绳在井底盘绕。当电梯轿厢到达底部时，这些缆绳就像一个巨大的弹簧，缓冲了着陆的冲击力。
It was not a gentle impact, Betty broke her back and both legs, but she was alive. There was a great roaring inside my head, she said, and blackness. Every chapter of history is made of lots of little stories, and that was especially true on July 28, 1945, the day a plane crashed into the Empire State Building. This is the view from the 79th floor. My name is Terez, 40-year-old, in 1945. I was 20 years old, and I worked for Catholic Relief Services on the 79th floor of the Empire State Building. My name is Gloria Paul. In 1945, I was working for the USO headquarters.
那并不是一次轻微的撞击，贝蒂背部和双腿骨折，但她活了下来。她说：“我脑子里有巨大的轰鸣声，然后是一片漆黑。”历史的每一章都是由许多小故事组成的，1945年7月28日那天尤其如此，那天一架飞机撞上了帝国大厦。这是从第79层看到的景象。我叫特蕾兹，1945年时我40岁。我当时20岁，在帝国大厦第79层的天主教救济会工作。我叫格洛丽亚·保罗。1945年，我在联合劳军组织总部工作。
I was on the 56th floor of the Empire State Building. It was just exciting every time I got off the train and went up to that 56th floor that was excitement. It was the Empire State Building, it's all this building in the world at that time. Rising a quarter of a mile straight up into the clouds, the world's tallest structure, the Empire State Building. From an observation platform, visitors look down on the New
我在帝国大厦的第56层。每次我下火车去往第56层时，都感到非常兴奋，那是令人激动的。那是帝国大厦，当时世界上最高的建筑。帝国大厦直插云霄，高达四分之一英里，是世界上最高的建筑。从观景台上，游客们俯瞰着纽约的天际线。
York skyline, 1200 feet below. Everyone on the ground looks so small, the cars, the people. You were really part of the clouds. The Empire State Building, a giant of steel and stone, a mark of 20th century progress. I'm Arthur Wengarton. I wrote the book The Sky is Falling, about the B-25 bomber that crashed into the Empire State Building. The pilot of the plane was Captain William Franklin Smith, a highly decorated pilot. Early in the morning on July 28, 1945, Captain Smith left from Massachusetts to the New York area. That morning was a misty cloudy day at the Empire State Building. We couldn't really
在1200英尺下方。地面上的每个人看起来都那么小，汽车、行人。你真的置身于云端之中。帝国大厦，这座钢铁与石头的巨人，是20世纪进步的标志。我是亚瑟·温加顿。我写了《天空正在坠落》一书，讲述了那架撞向帝国大厦的B-25轰炸机。飞机的飞行员是威廉·富兰克林·史密斯上尉，一位获得过许多勋章的飞行员。1945年7月28日清晨，史密斯上尉从马萨诸塞州出发前往纽约地区。那天早上，帝国大厦笼罩在雾蒙蒙的云层中。我们真的无法
see the ground from the 79th floor. And it was so foggy outside. I was looking out of the window. There was nothing to see. It was just like peace soup. It was like a London fog. It was very foggy in New York this morning when an Army B-25 twin engine bomber passed over La Guadilla Field and asked for a weather report. When Captain Smith called into LaGuardia Field and said, I request clearance to land. The tower said, we have almost zero visibility here. I suggest you do not land here at LaGuardia. The pilot was warned that the weather was bad and that the tower of the Empire State Building,
从第79层看到地面。外面雾太大了。我向窗外望去。什么也看不见。就像豌豆汤一样。就像伦敦的雾。那天早上纽约雾气非常浓，一架陆军B-25双引擎轰炸机飞过拉瓜迪亚机场并请求天气报告。当史密斯上尉呼叫拉瓜迪亚机场并说：“我请求降落许可。”塔台说：“我们这里的能见度几乎为零。我建议你不要在拉瓜迪亚降落。”飞行员被警告天气恶劣，而且帝国大厦的塔楼，
a landmark for Ammon in this area, could not be seen. Smith said, thank you very much and signed off. He ignored it. After over 50 missions in Europe, flying in the worst weather conditions imaginable, what could possibly happen to him here in the United States? And so he started to make a little bit of a turn which brought him over Midtown Manhattan. And as he started to straighten out, the clouds broke up enough for him to realize he was flying among skyscrapers.
该地区飞行员的地标，根本看不见。史密斯说：“非常感谢”，然后切断了通讯。他忽略了警告。在欧洲执行了50多次任务，在难以想象的最恶劣天气条件下飞行，在美国这里能出什么事呢？于是他开始稍微转弯，这使他飞到了曼哈顿中城上空。当他开始拉平机身时，云层散开了一些，让他意识到自己正飞行在摩天大楼之间。
On a foggy Saturday morning, five blocks north of the Empire State Building, James E. Eger was dictating into his sound scriber machine a letter to Dean Crawford of the University of Michigan. He was interrupted by the sound of a plane rolling down Fifth Avenue, at less than a thousand feet. and you can hear him on the tape, dictating the letter asud which is the impact of the bomber into the Empire State Building. At about five minutes of ten I got up from my desk and that was the end of the office as it existed. We are delaying the start of our regularly scheduled program to bring you a special news report on the crash of an airplane into the Empire State Building. Columbia Station's very far-cavenation report is due to the end of the sudden the building felt like it was going to just topple right over.
在一个雾蒙蒙的周六早晨，在帝国大厦以北五个街区，詹姆斯·E·埃格正在对着他的录音机口述一封给密歇根大学迪恩·克劳福德的信。他被飞机沿着第五大道低空飞行的声音打断了，高度不到一千英尺。你可以在录音带中听到他口述信件，随后就是轰炸机撞击帝国大厦的声音。大约9点55分，我从办公桌前站起来，那间办公室就不复存在了。我们推迟了常规节目的开始，为您带来关于一架飞机撞上帝国大厦的特别新闻报道。哥伦比亚电台的报道是因为突然的撞击，大楼感觉好像要直接倒塌了。
It just threw me across the room room and I landed against the wall. People were screaming and looking at each other and didn't know what to do. We didn't know there was a bomber. But what happened? A B-25 Mitchell bomber on a flight, apparently a routine flight from Boston to Newark or New York City, crashed into the 78th or the 79th story of the Empire State Building and what the final toll will be, there is no way of telling it this time. On the other side of the office, all I could see was flames. Mr. Fountain was walking through the office when the plane hit the building and he was on
它直接把我甩到了房间对面，我撞在了墙上。人们在尖叫，互相看着，不知道该怎么办。我们不知道那是一架轰炸机。但发生了什么？一架B-25米切尔轰炸机在从波士顿飞往纽瓦克或纽约市的常规飞行中，撞上了帝国大厦的第78或79层，目前还无法确定最终的伤亡人数。在办公室的另一边，我所能看到的只有火焰。方丹先生在飞机撞击大楼时正走过办公室，他身上
fire. His clothes were on fire, his head was on fire. Six of us managed to get into this one office that seemed to be untouched by the fire and closed the door before it engulfed us. There was no doubt that the other people must have been killed. The four alarm fires drawn every piece of fire apparatus to the busy scene of Fifth Avenue in 34th Street, in the heart of Manhattan, and hundreds of office workers were trapped a fifth of a mile above the street level.
着火了。他的衣服着火了，他的头也着火了。我们六个人设法躲进了这间似乎没有被火势波及的办公室，并在火势吞没我们之前关上了门。毫无疑问，其他人肯定已经遇难了。四级火警调动了每一件消防设备前往第五大道和34街的繁忙现场，在曼哈顿的中心地带，数百名办公室职员被困在离地面五分之一英里的高空。
It was a very small universe at that point. You sort of stuck there, and then Ireland would fire all around us. A couple of the women had passed out from the smoke and I had a handkerchief in my pocket and so I used that to cover my nose and mouth to protect me from the fumes. But I didn't expect to get out alive. Somebody opened the window and I'm sitting there and I thought about my rings and I'm sitting there. And I thought about my rings, and I figured somebody else might as well have you sat of them. So I took them off my fingers,
那一刻，世界变得非常狭小。你被困在那里，周围全是火。有几位女士因为烟雾昏倒了，我口袋里有一块手帕，所以我用它捂住鼻子和嘴，以保护自己免受烟雾伤害。但我没指望能活着出去。有人打开了窗户，我坐在那里，想到了我的戒指。我坐在那里，想到了我的戒指，我想反正别人也可能拿走它们。于是我把它们从手指上摘下来，
and it's proof of them out the window. We have contacted the night witness, Mr. Phil Kirby, as a grant advertising agency. We've contacted him by telephone, Mr. Kirby. I looked out of the window, and it was very, very smokey, terribly smokey. And I looked out of the window, and I saw two girls trapped on the 78th floor. That's above our floor. You see, I'm in the 76th, there's two flights up. A man appeared, you know, a few stories down.
把它们扔出了窗外。我们已经联系了目击者菲尔·柯比先生，他在一家广告代理公司。我们通过电话联系了他，柯比先生。我向窗外望去，烟雾非常非常浓，极其浓重。我向窗外望去，看到两个女孩被困在第78层。那是在我们楼上。你看，我在76层，那是两层楼之上。一个男人出现了，你知道，在下面几层。
He looked up and he seemed to look up to us. And I think Charlotte was sitting, you know, with her legs dangling inside the office and we were holding on to her. It gave her a better view of what was going on. Then one girl got out of the window and I said, get back, get back, get back. I said, the final being here soon, Bill.
他抬头看，似乎是在看我们。我想夏洛特当时坐着，你知道，双腿悬在办公室里，我们拉着她。这让她能更好地看清外面发生了什么。然后一个女孩从窗户爬了出来，我说：“回去，回去，回去。”我说：“消防队很快就会到这里，比尔。”
So she said, we'll come quickly because our whole office is in flames. Yes, can't wait long. All right, you get back now, big, good, good, you're going to get back. I guess he was trying to give us a little solace. I know that you're there, don't worry. And that was a connection with the rest of the world. We all felt a little better to know that someone knew we were there.
所以她说：“快点来，因为我们整个办公室都在燃烧。”是的，不能等太久。好了，你现在回去，很好，很好，你会回去的。我想他是在试图给我们一点安慰。我知道你们在那里，别担心。那是与外界的联系。知道有人知道我们在那里，我们都感觉好了一些。
When the plane hit the outside of the building, it kept on going, and the engines continued about 20 feet into the building and went down through the elevator shaft. What was an elevator shaft? When the plane hit, parts of the engine flew ahead and severed the lifting cables of the elevators that had been at the 79th floor. Sitting in one of the elevators was a young elevator operator named Betty Lou Oliver. She started to plunge down the elevator shaft from the 79th floor. Cables of two of the cars were sheared, sending both elevators crashing to the subbasements
当飞机撞击大楼外侧时，它继续向前冲，引擎继续深入大楼约20英尺，并穿过了电梯井。什么是电梯井？当飞机撞击时，引擎部件飞向前方，切断了当时位于第79层的电梯的提升缆绳。坐在其中一部电梯里的是一位名叫贝蒂·露·奥利弗的年轻电梯操作员。她开始从第79层沿着电梯井坠落。两部电梯的缆绳被切断，导致两部电梯都坠毁在帝国大厦的地下室。
of the Empire State Building. She was alive. She broke her pelvis and her back and her neck. But she survived. Now, Reverend John J. Morrison has just come in and he has just given the last rights to a man who jumped and landed on a parapet. I think it's on the 60, I don't know, 65th or 66th floor. It's down below, is that anyway? Yeah, I see.
她还活着。她骨盆、背部和颈部骨折。但她幸存了下来。现在，约翰·J·莫里森牧师刚刚赶到，他刚刚为一名跳楼并落在护墙上的人做了临终祈祷。我想是在第60，我不知道，65层还是66层。是在下面，是吗？是的，我看到了。
My name is Sharon Deering, Sizzascus. My father was Paul Deering. My father was in a corner office on the 79th floor. He either was forced out by the crash and the concussion or he actually had to jump when he saw a whole place on fire. It's more likely that he had to jump. You know if you were ever up 79 floors and looking down, to think of someone having to jump out of a window up there, that's what I think of. We're speaking from the Empire State Building,
我叫莎伦·迪林，西扎斯库斯。我父亲是保罗·迪林。我父亲当时在第79层的一个拐角办公室里。他要么是被撞击和冲击波震出来的，要么是在看到整个地方着火时不得不跳楼。更有可能的是他不得不跳楼。你知道，如果你曾经在79层高处向下看，想到有人不得不从那里的窗户跳出来，这就是我所想到的。我们正在从帝国大厦进行报道，
near the top of the building, the 79th floor where firemen are picking up the debris caused by the crash of a Mitchell B-25 bomber into this building right about 40 feet from where we stand. All of a sudden he was here with firemen and they're coming to rescue us. All dressed up in their raincoats and whatever they wear, you know, when it was just wonderful. We climbed out through the broken glass. I was just grateful to be alive. The walls are still hot, the brick and stone walls that we have our hand on as we talk are still hot with the flame that has been out for over an hour now.
在大楼顶部附近，第79层，消防员们正在清理米切尔B-25轰炸机撞击大楼造成的残骸，就在我们站的地方大约40英尺处。突然间，他和消防员们就在这里，他们来救我们了。他们都穿着雨衣，无论他们穿什么，你知道，当时真是太棒了。我们从破碎的玻璃中爬了出来。我只是很感激能活着。墙壁仍然很热，我们说话时手扶着的砖石墙壁仍然因为一个多小时前熄灭的火焰而发烫。
112 flights later. We got to the bottom floor, but we didn't know what happened until we came out of the building. I see crowds of people all kind of looking at each other. I said, what happened? What happened? What happened? And he pointed up to the 79th floor.
112层楼之后。我们到达了底层，但在走出大楼之前，我们不知道发生了什么。我看到人群都在互相看着。我说：“发生了什么？发生了什么？发生了什么？”他指了指第79层。
I saw the tail of a B25 sticking out. Well, we're going to get off there here very shortly because we have the story told now, the B25 two-engine Army bomber crashing into the Empire of State Building, just a few minutes before 10 o'clock. We have been going for a few minutes. That morning 11 people died in the offices and three in the plane for a total of 14 people.
我看到B-25的尾部露在外面。好吧，我们很快就要结束了，因为我们现在已经讲完了这个故事，B-25双引擎陆军轰炸机在10点前几分钟撞上了帝国大厦。我们已经进行了几分钟了。那天早上，办公室里有11人死亡，飞机上有3人，总共14人。
This is Don Gutter and this is the National Broadcasting Company. We return you now to the music of the first piano quartet. The view from the 79th floor was produced by Joe Richmond, Samarra Fremark and Sarah Kramer for Radio Diaries. If you've ever turned on NPR in the afternoon and you hear some beautifully composed, sound rich, first person documentary that knocked you out. It was probably Radio Diaries. Do yourself a favor. Go straight to the source and subscribe to their newly revamped podcast.
这是唐·古特，这里是全国广播公司。现在我们将带您回到第一钢琴四重奏的音乐中。《第79层的视角》由乔·里士满、萨马拉·弗雷马克和莎拉·克莱默为《广播日记》制作。如果你在下午打开NPR，听到一些制作精美、声音丰富、让你震撼的第一人称纪录片。那很可能就是《广播日记》。帮自己一个忙。直接去源头，订阅他们新改版的播客。
It's so good. You can find it at radiodiaries.org. 99% Invisible is Sam Greenspan Avery Truffleman and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. in San Francisco. I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm I'm There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它太棒了。你可以在radiodiaries.org找到它。《99%隐形》的制作人员是萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼和我罗曼·马斯。我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW和旧金山美国建筑师协会的一个项目。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。